voici la liste de tous les ingrédients
toxiques qu'il faut absolument bannir de
notre ventes annuelles pas de bpa
pas de msg pas de bh a ni de bht pas de
soja pas de sésame naturellement ni
noisette ni eux ni lait ni beurre sel ni
sucre ni blé par dans quels sont les
ingrédients quand cette année je vous
préviens je vais former une équipe de
choc un peu comme des forces de police
il y aura des vérifications et il y aura
destruction de chaque gâteau hors normes
et procédures contre les contrevenants
oui alors qui sera ma première
volontaires pour rentrer dans mes forces
de police je crois que ça va être aimé
mitchell quoi voilà ce qu'on récolte
quand on est en retard chéri non qu'est
ce que j'entends regardez c'est la mer
bizarre qui sort pas de chez elle mais
qu est-ce que cette bille et les filles
mattia passé la nuit à vomir dessus tout
va bien même si j'ai pas beaucoup dormi
quel malheur sa tristesse va déteindre
sur moi et voici amy tu arrives à
abandonner des enfants pour aller
travailler si dur mais j'ai aussi besoin
de choses comme un peu de pognon et oui
à tout à l'heure dans elle travaille
tellement ça m'épate cette fille
travaille tellement oui c'est ce que je
viens de dire riquet
on est en train de suer c'est parfaite
ça nous fait devenir dingue
à notre époque c'est impossible d'être
une mère parfaite c'est sûr devenait
d'emera digne au samedi à la plage c'est
génial c'est très excitant sa manche je
vous adore